Speaker 1: I want to call your attention back
to that really wacky lawyer, Sydney Powell,
who was working with Donald Trump on his fraud
claims after the 2020 election and then wasn't.
And then it was said when she went seemingly
completely crazy that she's acting on her
own.
But she was at the White House meeting with
Trump in the Oval Office.
That lady, Sydney Powell, she now appeared
on one of these completely wacky shows and
claims that Democrats killed an aide to then
Senator Kelly Lefler, who died in a car accident.
You might remember this story back during
that special election where you had both David
Perdue and Kelly Lefler in Georgia facing
special Senate elections.
A 20 year old staffer of Kelly Leafless Campaign
died in a car crash.
And it was a really crazy thing where it was
like the day or the day before a rally.
And I'm trying to remember, Lefler maybe missed
a rally as a result of it or something like
that.
You go back and you look at the stories.
Kelly Lefler herself tweeting, it is with
extremely heavy, with an extremely heavy heart
that we mourn the loss of Harrison deal.
My heart aches for his family, and Jeff and
I will continue to surround them in love and
prayer in the days ahead.
Harrison was a beloved member of our campaign
team.
The accident was a multi vehicle accident
in south Georgia, and it forced Lefler and
Kempe Brian Kemp to cancel their plans to
join Mike Pence in Savannah for a rally.
OK, so Sydney Powell goes on some show and
refers to that as Democrats blowing up one
of Kelly levelers staffers cars.
It's not only absolutely insane and completely
unsubstantiated, isn't it kind of disrespectful
to the family of Harrison Deal as well?
Not that not that people like Sydney Powell
care about stuff like that.
Let's listen three of that
Speaker 7: and say what we are dealing with
here is pervasive and very, very dark.
It's organized.
It's well-funded.
Speaker 1: Is she talking about the plot to
steal the election?
Speaker 7: It's.
Pure evil, they are willing to kill people,
a la Kelly leafless aide in Georgia who was
suddenly blown up in his car on the way to
a rally.
Speaker 1: That's crazy.
That's completely insane.
I hope people understand the degree to which
that is absurd for her.
Speaker 7: He happened to be dating Governor
Kemp's daughter, Governor Kim was considering,
I think at that point, a signature on it.
And then the Georgia Bureau of Investigation
agent who was investigating that he was the
lead investigator was suddenly dead within
a week.
And suddenly we don't hear anything else about
any of that.
We are talking about trillions of dollars
of global wealth.
At issue here, the leadership and control
of the of the most powerful country on the
face of the earth.
Speaker 1: How insane is this woman?
Some of you might remember she was interviewed
by I believe it was an Australian media outlet
a couple of weeks ago, and we covered it.
And she genuinely seems delusional.
I am not joking like she seems to have no
connection to reality whatsoever.
This actually was a little bit of a conspiracy
theory that started spreading before the Facebook
post on December 5th claimed Joe Biden killed
the Kelly Lefler staffer.
And as PolitiFact points out, Harrison Deal,
a campaign staffer for Senator Kelly Lefler,
died after a three vehicle collision.
A spokesperson for the police department in
the town where it happened said a flatbed
truck struck deals vehicle from behind, causing
him to hit another vehicle.
And there is just no evidence that Joe Biden
was involved.
And what's really crazy about these stories
is that the story starts to get some oxygen
to the point where someone will want to put
out like a fact check.
And then the fact that it gets fact checked
becomes part of the conspiracy.
Like you and I might read that and say, oh,
OK, it's like in really clear and simple terms,
there is no actual evidence that there was
foul play here, that Joe Biden killed Kelly
Lefler staffer, that this was a murder.
There's just there's just no evidence of it.
You and I might see it that way, but the believers
will see the fact check as part of the conspiracy.
And this is a really common tenet, or some
people call it a tenant, like when they say
pundit's God, that pisses me off.
OK, anyway, it's a tenet.
And one of the tenets of conspiracy ism is
that once you've generated the conspiracy
theory, evidence for it supports your belief
in it, evidence against it supports your belief
in it, because obviously the evidence against
it is planted.
Not finding evidence supports your belief
in it because the evidence must have been
covered up or hidden.
And you get into the circle of conspiracies.
I mean, some people can never get out.
You know, Trump talks about flushing toilets
10 or 15 times.
You just you can't flush your way out of this.
It just stays there and it lingers and it
lingers and there's really no way out of it.
So there's Sydney Powell, very, very dangerous
woman, a disgusting woman, and someone who
seems to be dealing with some pretty serious
issues of her own.